hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video wir spielen heute
mal wieder zusammen bomba pingu das ist
ja ein spiel wo man so bomben schmeißen
muss wir können einfach auf spiel
starten klicken dann steht schon suche
auch ihren direkten gegner gefunden ich
kann mich jetzt quasi hiermit den
maustasten einfach bewegen hier eine
bombe hinlegen und die bombe explodiert
dann und wenn die bombe explodiert ist
bekomme ich neuerdings beim gegner
eigentlich gerade afk und wenn ich dann
hin bombe hinsetze und die bombe jetzt
einfach mal explodiert seht ihr schon
dass beispielsweise in altem rauskommt
und jetzt sehe ich auch kommen gegner
ist doch nicht ab jetzt kann ich
beispielsweise zwei bomben setzen und
dadurch dass ich jetzt bei bomben setzen
kamen träge ich natürlich jetzt kann ich
schon vier bomben setzen bei 1 2 3 4 und
das ist jetzt fünf bomben und die bomben
explodieren alle am stück und jetzt habe
ich hier noch ein bisschen da war was
macht mein gegner da eigentlich das ist
allerdings komplett egal was mein gegner
da unten macht denn ich möchte dieses
game hier heute nur kurz nutzen um mit
euch über etwas zu reden und zwar ist es
gerade 23 uhr mein gegner hat sich
einfach ok ich hab' ich habe du hast
gewonnen ich habe jetzt einfach mal
andere gegner genommen ich glaube der
ist jetzt sogar jahr der spielt sogar
tatsächlich gerade es ist gerade 23 uhr
19 jetzt gerade umgesprungen deutsche
zeit und ich komme gerade von einem
amerika urlaub wieder wo ich ja drei
tage in new york war dann drei tage und
dann noch mal einen tag new york und
dann weiter zurück geflogen nach
frankfurt und darüber möchte ich jetzt
gerade einfach mal so ein bisschen mit
euch reden weil online er sammelt sich
jetzt da hinten noch nicht wirklich die
ganze zeit er hat sich die ganzen alten
sound eingesammelt ich möchte mit euch
darüber reden weil ich um
9 uhr deutsche zeit wieder in frankfurt
angekommen bin euer gott es ist richtig
spannend hier das ja weil ich bin tot
fakt ist james abott in dieses game ich
bin um 9 uhr deutsche zeit in frankfurt
angekommen und hatte ganz tag vor mir
und habe ich habe die letzten beiden
nächte insgesamt vier stunden geschlafen
weil von ll nach new york man nachtflug
und von new york nach frankfurt waren
nach flug und ich kann im flugzeug nie
länger als zwei stunden schlafen
deswegen augenringe deswegen total ko
und heute den ganzen tag irgendwie im
bett gelegen und total fertig
gesundheitlich und ich möchte mit euch
jetzt mal so allgemein über youtube
jetzt gerade reden
ich wollte nämlich eigentlich heute ein
ganz normales video aufnehmen wo ich
clash royal spiele das ist ein neues
spiel von den machern von clash of games
und da bin ich in letzter zeit ein
bisschen süchtig geworden und deswegen
hab ich bock drauf das ganze einfach mal
hochzuladen allerdings hat es dann nicht
geklappt weil ja irgendwie meine elgato
hd 60 irgendwie diese neue da habe ich
die hat da irgendwie kein ton im
kriegsfall twitter wissen woran das
liegt also ich hatte quasi einfach
iphone angeschlossen und habe keinen ton
da gibt nicht mal irgendein ausschlag
angezeigt bei der app ok ich bin ich bin
ich bin tot ich hatte quasi keinen ton
und das spiel zu zocken ohne ton macht
nicht allzu viel sinn weil ich auch
einen pack open box betrug
wie heißt es da ich habe mir extra mit
geld so ein bisschen juwelen gekauft und
wollte halt so tun opening machen aber
kisten ob desktop hat nicht geklappt
weil der ton einfach nicht da aber das
heißt wenn ihr da was genaueres wissen
schreibt mir das mal bitte in die
kommentare welche weise verbunden aber
worum es eigentlich gehen sollte war ich
wollte dieses video aufnehmen und ich
war einfach disco und so möchte ich
einfach kein video aufnehmen ihr wisst
ja dass ich studiere und nicht youtube
hauptberuflich mache weil youtube
hauptberuflich wenn wir zu wenig
allerdings studium mit youtube ist schon
ein bisschen zu viel gerade ich habe
beispielsweise am 18.04
die abgabe meiner praktikums arbeit ich
bin demnächst auch noch beim 2 tv shows
mit dabei wo ich mich eigentlich schon
darauf freue ich werde nach österreich
fahren demnächst das wird euch denke ich
auch freund also darf ich allerdings
noch nichts genaueres sagen und ich habe
auch so unglaublich viele hacker glück
war er ist er tot
du hast gewonnen und es gibt auch
allgemeine letzter zeit unglaublich
viele menschen die mir sehr sehr doll
ans herz gewachsen sind mit denen ich
sehr viel zeit verbringen möchte und
alles quasi unter einen hut zu packen
also genug freizeit youtube studium
und alles was neben youtube noch
dazukommen wie beispielsweise zum tv
sachen und so geht nicht wenn man nicht
dann immer jede nacht nur so drei vier
stunden schläft ihr seht es
wahrscheinlich schon in meinem gesicht
ich habe augenringe ich fühle mich echt
gerade total ko ich will allerdings
nicht schlafen weil ich dann weiß dass
einfach morgen kein video kommentiert
bzw
das video seht ist ja quasi schon morgen
und man hat ja dann auch den ehrgeiz
dass man wirklich jeden tag was
hochladen will weil das sonst so ein
bisschen ist luca die letzten vier tage
kamen schon keine videos wisst ihr was
ich meine darüber wollte ich einfach ein
bisschen mit euch reden und euch nur
sagen dass demnächst die videos in den
nächsten zwei drei wochen weniger
bearbeitet werden also dass ich länger
so am stück laber wie ich das jetzt
gerade mache und dann nicht an die face
kamran summe und dann teilweise die
musik einfach mal so im hintergrund
jetzt belassen wie sie ist und dann halt
auch einfach mal weiß ich nicht mein tag
nichts hochladen in der woche oder dass
die videos dann vielleicht mal vier
minuten 30 gehen anstatt zehn minuten
oder irgendwie so ich möchte euch das
nur sagen und euch da um verständnis
bitten das ist quasi auch schon das
worüber ich reden wollte einfach nur um
euch zu sagen ja auch freunde ich bin
derzeit einfach wirklich todes ko ich
versuche die kopf ich bin allein ein av
dem ich kann ja seine kugeln auf
wegschubsen ich versuche alles unter
einen hut zu kriegen und das ist auch
mein primäres ziel der zeit im leben
dass ich irgendwie alles irgendwie oft
kette kriege weil ich keinerlei ich habe
gewonnen ich versuche alles auf die
kette zu kriegen und ich denke das ist
ein problem bei mir also ich bin kein
mensch der einfach sagen kann ja ich
mache jetzt mal heute kein video oder
joel erneut nicht für die uni soll
es gibt so viele sachen die derzeit in
meinem leben so einen hohen stellenwert
haben dass ich sie einfach nicht einfach
so kunden kann von jetzt auf gleich dass
ich da einfach nur den schlaf hat quasi
ein bisschen quitte das schöne ist mehr
oder weniger schön dass mein praktikum
es vorbei
er holt viel spaß gemacht allerdings hat
es natürlich auch sehr viel zeit in
anspruch genommen
aber ich kann jetzt wieder ein bisschen
mehr schlafen bau.de dabei in allem ein
ort kann d'italia gar nicht kicken muss
mich quasi nur die ganze zeit irgendwie
verteidigen hiermit meinen kugeln damit
der milchbauer hat der eine krasse
explosion ich werde ja nicht mehr was
die ist ja denn da um die ecke gekommen
ich könnte mal ganz kurz die bomber
penguin rede mal kurz mit euch um das
thema zu ende zu bringen mir geht es in
diesem video einfach darum um euch zu
zeigen dass mir derzeit sehr viele
sachen geschwüren in meinem kopf um das
ist so praktikums arbeit drei klausuren
im mai youtube freunde schlaf freizeit
familie alles irgendwie in den kopf rein
und das nimmt mich derzeit alles
unglaublich mit ich bin kein mensch der
immer seine gefühle raus hat es gibt ja
youtube laden jeden zweiten tag info
video hoch ich habe das sehr lange zeit
war einfach mit mitgetragen und mir
gedacht ja seht schon besser aber es
wird quasi immer schlimmer dadurch dass
immer noch mehr dazu kamen dann wäre
dann auch nicht nein sagen wenn man
viele anfragen bekommt man da und da
dabei sein will oder man zu der uniqa
man ja nicht nein sagen und ich möchte
jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt keine
kommentare lesen die ja mach doch eine
pause blabla das persönliche center ich
bin euch sehr dankbar dafür dass voll
nicht böse kommen aber ich versuche das
derzeit einfach bei mir so ein bisschen
das zeitmanagement so ein bisschen
besser hinzukriegen dass ich mir sage
okay youtube-videos in den nächsten drei
wochen werden ein bisschen weniger
bearbeitet und dafür kann ich dann mehr
zeit im schlaf und mehr zeit in das
studium investieren was mir derzeit
einfach wichtiger ist als youtube sage
ich mal ich weiß jeder stellt youtube
über sein leben
von den ganzen leuten die irgendwie
erfolgreich sind wenn ich erfolgreich
aber ja ich also ich wollte euch nur
sagen dass die videos in den nächsten
tagen wochen ein bisschen weniger
bearbeitet werden und vielleicht noch
mal dann wöchentlich nur vier oder fünf
videos und vielleicht auch nicht so lang
aber ich versuche alles irgendwie
hinzukriegen und wollte nur sagen dass
mir das leid tut ja